it's always easier to start outside cuz
you if it's not raining you film outside
if it is raining you go inside can I
interject real quick sure our first
thing wasn't we shot you in the house
sorry what's our philosophy well you
have to start before you can stop y it's
hard to stop something it's in motion
it's hard to start something but once
you have it's hard to stop it once it's
in motion it's a good lesson in life you
cannot it's hard to stop something once
you've started so sometimes you have to
just
start I've been teaching NYU for the
past 15 years and uh the issue is
whether you're in film school or not
film school where you get the money to
shoot where you get the money
to for completion to finish your film
and I tell people you just have to be
inventive and you got to look under
every nook and
cranny
to get it done it's not there's not
there's nothing I could tell somebody
that's going to be like the Golden Trail
and you're going to find a pot of
gold you know at at the end is that's
just not the way this industry works but
how do you get a film financed and how
do you get distribution for a film so
that's the that's the main thing there's
no clean way to do either of those
things it's uh it's you know sometimes
certain things work and sometimes they
don't I had seen a film that I was not
impressed with and it inspired me to do
anything uh it was the idea like don't
let perfect be the enemy of good so uh
called up James I'm like I'm pulling the
trigger on this I've got a bunch of
investors who put money into other films
before my thought was Let's Jam it out
and get it done so James had a
distributor in front of his approaching
a distributor in advance is something
that really helps uh especially for this
film what I did is I had my movie
pernicious which is coming out in
theaters soon um that all the
Distributors saw um when it was playing
festivals and they had made bids on it
and the Distributors that we didn't end
up selling the film to I approached and
said hey um you know they they put in an
offer for it and I said hey if I made a
film in the same genre would you buy it
and they said yes and so they pre-bought
the film and so these films were
pre-sold before they were made
it was very easy to finance them based
off of they were already they were made
so it's like hey once the film is
delivered you get x amount of dollars
from the distributor it's very easy to
say hey can you finance this because I'm
literally basically borrowing money from
you for like a little bit of time and
then it comes in he said specifically
what he was looking for as opposed to
making up a movie that you're like this
is my passion project it was uh here's
what distributor wants they basically
said as long as um I'm writing and
director directing uh which on one and
then I swung it as a two film deal that
I would write both with Zach Zach would
direct one and I would direct one and
then they said that it had to be um like
ghost house type stuff so like you know
genre films with a supernatural element
that's that's what's big right now for
for genre so it was haunted house uh
film with a ghost girl and inside that
Niche we could do whatever we wanted so
we came up with about 12 different
concepts pitched them to him he chose
which ones he liked and then we wrote
them and we literally wrote them over
Christmas my girlfriend is very very
kind and understanding so over Christmas
we were locked in our offices sleeping
there writing 17 hours a day jamming it
out and we got uh we wrote Restoration
in 5 days for the first draft and then
Bethany we wrote in seven days and then
we both went our separate ways to do our
polishes on each so I we directed
restoration he was going to direct
Bethany uh so I polished restoration he
polished Bethany so once we had that uh
we already had the distribution I talked
to my investors and at this budget we
had a good mg minimum guarantee so it
wasn't that much of a risk financially
um it was a real thing to move forward
with so we did and it's you know it's
micr budget films it's hard uh it's
really hard but we have fantastic Crews
and wonderful people that we're working
with and then we have begged for every
favor we could get
so we then Cru up cast up locked it down
and started shooting then we did them
back to back so we did we're doing six
day weeks our restoration was 14
shooting days six day weeks uh then 3
days down and then started Bethany first
14 shooting
days
cut all right that's a
cut Easy Does It is a free willing
Adventure comedy about two friends Jack
and Scotty robbing their way to San and
Clemente along the way they form an
unlikely friendship with their hostage
Colin with their adversaries in Hot
Pursuit they learned that chasing dreams
isn't always easy the hardest part of
making an indie film without a doubt is
getting it financed in order to raise
the budget we needed to make this movie
uh we started putting together this
package for investors to see um we made
a promotional concept trailer which
would show them kind of the vibe and
style and tone of the movie we wrote
very extensive business plan
illustrating the potential Returns the
film could gain you know comparing it to
other previous uh similar films these
folks who are potentially interested in
investing want to see that they're going
to get a return and the way that you do
that is show them that the film will get
a distribution we live in this great age
where all of a sudden there's a lot of
ways to get your movie out there it's no
longer you know in theaters or straight
to video the way that you show them that
they'll get distribution can be one of
several things either it's a genre that
really sells well like horror or um as
with us you try to attach name actors
name actors can really kind of be the
difference between an equally good movie
um getting lost in the Clutter and
getting you know either decent or very
good distribution of people actually
seeing the thing and the thing making
money The Catch 22 with that is that um
they kind of need to know that you're
serious and that often means having the
collateral having the budget there to
say hey I can put my money where my
mouth is so now you're caught in this
Catch 22 right where like the investors
are like oh yeah no I like your script
I'll invest if so and so comes on and
meanwhile the actor says that's you know
I like the role I'll come on if you for
sure have the you know have the capital
have the budget I would say the mo Moth
Man prophecies which was another Richard
Gear film um was and and there was one
moment one seminal moment uh and and
again that was a film that that had been
shopped all over town every company
independent medium big studio all passed
on it I wasn't involved at the time the
agent shopped it the writer I had
produced before I was I actually got to
produce his first film and he came to me
and
said would you read this and I fell in
love with it and is and and then I
learned it had been passed
on and I I found there was one company
and only one company that hadn't seen it
that was Lakes Shore wonderful company
so I said you know what I will I will um
invest time in this and I will take it
to Lakeshore
and
um and I knew it was that was it there
was literally one buyer in the whole
world I could sell this to so I went to
them and they read it three Executives
and they called me the following Monday
morning typical Monday Morning Call
right brilliant story we loved the Craft
um it was intriguing based on a true
story oh my God fascinating beautiful
beautiful beautiful responses from all
of them at which point one of them said
so thanks so much for sending it over
it's going to be a
pass only in Hollywood and I thought
that wait a minute I'm sorry did you
just say it's going to be a pass all
this all the all the you your you know
all this laudatory language and then
you're dead and there was a long pause
cuz I knew this was it this was the last
man standing there was no other option
and that was the company I mentioned
this earlier that was the company the
moment when I said I respectfully pass
on your pass and there was some nervous
laughter I said look of course you can
pass but based on our relationship and
our respect for one another I would ask
him before you make a final final Final
Decision let me just come in and talk to
you so I I went to this meeting I told
these three Executives the story of my
relationship with my dad why because the
script when I read it initially uh was
so moving to me because the character
played by Richard Gear uh is so lost in
grief after his beloved young wife dies
and a lot of what the texture of it were
would was reminiscent to me of what I
felt after my dad's death he was my best
friend
and and to me this
film was a great film in its own right
it it deserved to get made and more
importantly it would be a private homage
to my dad and so I cared deeply about it
so I went into this meeting with three
people who'd read it and and said nice
things about it but passed on it and um
so I felt the door was open just a
little
bit and I never referenced the script I
never talked about the title I just
simply told him the story of my dad I
told him who my dad was I told him about
our friendship and our our relationship
and and the love that we had and what it
was like when unexpectedly never having
been sick he just passed away and what
that was to my family and to
me and I just spent not long 12 minutes
10 minutes telling the story at the end
of which I simply said I cannot
imagine anyone filmmaker actor audience
doesn't matter who will not be moved
we're wired whether we lost someone or
not we're wired to understand the
tragedy and and and and despair of
losing someone so close to
you and they huddled and they changed
their mind bottom line they changed
their mind and we got to make this film
and it's a great film um it wasn't as
big as pretty woman but um but it was
well received and actually become more
popular over over over the years and I'm
very proud of the
film but in a way as a learning lesson
it's like you know we talked earlier
about never take no for an
answer and I think what I came away from
that was if you are you know if you're
ballsy enough if you're bold and
courageous enough just to it's like get
naked in public if you're willing to get
naked in
public people are impressed right
because we all know about vibration and
frequency and when if you're like you
know when you're deeply moved and you're
in that very deeply authentic place and
and there's no BS we know it it's
real that's very attractive to us and
that's what we want to put on a big
screen and that's what they got they got
why this is going to move the audience
and therefore potentially be a success
and the film was successful as a
business matter but I that's not you
know it I don't measure it in those
terms I just think how do I get a yes
from these people so I can do what I so
desperately want to do as a creative
person Neil never stopped believing in
his band John Jonathan K never stopped
believing and Arnell never start stopped
believing and we as filmmakers like
never stopped believing it's like really
a theme
and you know we kind of jumped out of
there on our own credit cards we didn't
have funding in place and everything and
the first time I saw a little clip that
Ramona put together I said we have to do
this and she's like well they're on tour
right now and I said right now we were
standing in a u Starbucks parking lot
she said yeah I said we're missing the
story it's unfolding like we have to go
now and she was like well we don't have
money and I said well we can't let that
stop us don't let that stop us so within
a week of that conversation we were on
the road just like putting stuff on
credit cards and and we just always knew
and there was one moment you know
because we were so small and we didn't
have a lot of money there was only five
of us on a road so there's two camera
operators one sound Rona myself and my
job was always sort of to to PA and you
know to drive and just dump footage and
just do kind of all the things anything
else that you know needed to be done and
I remember at one point we were probably
like maybe at the six venue and I was
sitting back there and it kind of dawned
on me I said we're like charging up a
storm we're following a rock band we
don't have any money we don't know what
the movie is we don't know anything
we're just out here and I watched like
10 minutes of our now in the dressing
room and he would he captivated me I
couldn't take my eyes off of him and
that's when I knew I was like we're
going to be all right like I knew we're
going to be all right yeah it was
probably about three years I had an
idealism that IID write the script and
it' be a David STS thing the first and
probably only David STS project and my
thing was so okay even though it's a
little dark and off be people are going
to want to make it you know people are
going to want to make this and make it
on a higher end and de budget level you
know like a few million and it was it
was a little naive on my end to think
that you know I was putting a lot of
restrictions on it you know I think when
you're going for money you need to know
what how willing how where are your
priorities for me my priority wasn't
controlling the material keeping the
script the same and and being able to
decide on having you know the final say
on casting like those are the kind of
things then that are going to push
investors away not to say that if I
embraced all those things anyone would
have jumped on board but ultimately I'm
making a movie that was dealing with
religious themes themes of sexuality you
know stuff that isn't
necessarily I every time I see an
independent film I'm like I don't know
how they got it financed and I mean I
always feel it as a compliment you know
especially when to see ones made like
I'm like how did that happen I think
every single film Finds Its Own Way um
and usually that way is totally
different than the previous way you know
I mean this this was it was just a long
process of really getting a lot of nose
at one point I think I calculated it was
like it start once it got like over like
150 nose or so I just I stopped counting
like I kept running chart and when it
was like hit that many of people like
financiers or producers or companies
production companies that had passed on
it then I just like stopped keeping a
number tally because it got a little
depressing you know I feel like I have a
thick skin but I think it's okay for
anyone to feel like 150 rejections on
the same script is is a little it could
be a little mind-numbing you know but um
it was you know but it was about I
thought the system would sort of serve
me a little better like I thought well I
made my first film and people saw it and
people liked it and now I've written the
script and it's a well-known author and
I have agents and it's going to it'll
it'll come together in the way it should
and it was kind of wrong for me to feel
that way because ultimately it came
together through whatever resources I
sort of engaged in build and so I had
support from you know film independent
that I had on my own that I had built
over over the years and they I got
brought into a program where I met a
producer who came on board that brought
financing you know so it was one of
those things that ended up being through
my own path and not say that as a as
anything negative towards the agency
route but just to say that like at no
point should you ever just sort of be
like okay well now I have reps and uh
they're going to get it all taken care
of like no at the end of the day you're
only you're always responsible for
yourself and I think financing is no
different um just about always staying
on top of anyone you know anyone who
might know someone with money and just
always staying persistent on it and and
keep on pushing and keep on pushing
because it's it's G to everyone's going
to say no I mean rarely do I have I I've
rarely ever heard of a story where
someone was like I was really I sent the
script out people liked it we got it
made like it that maybe happens with
genre films but I don't think it ever
happens with a a drama or comedy or
especially not a dark comedy you know
well I think that when you want to when
you're looking for money you have to
have
a you that be tough tough as nails and
not be
uh deterred by
nose all it takes that one person that
one
grant that one
scholarship you know
money can show
up can fall out of the sky sometimes I
mean that's not something that that you
have to wait for one of
my one of my
own most favorite quotes is
by Brooklyn Dodger owner Branch Ricky
who signed Jackie
Robinson and the quote is
this luck is a residue of
design
so if you're working and busting your
ass you a better chance of luck smiling
down upon
you but you're just
chilling and not extending any injury
excuse me not extending any
energy no get it from
go you're not we're not seeing that
elbow grease we're not seeing
initiative we're not seeing that Blood
Sweat and
Tears very rarely
will you find yourself in a lucky
situation speaking of which but but you
can't depend on luck though you can't
depend on luck I've been very
lucky
uh be honest when I decide want to be
filmmaker there was only one
African-American director work in
Hollywood his name is Michael schz
director one of my favorite film films
coolly high and so when I would tell my
afri American friends you
know they're
like do black people they let black
people direct films and so I never
ever thought about the
odds a lot of times you think about
stuff like that it could be
a self-inflicted
paralysis
but uh I knew I wanted to
do
and I was
the
committed that through hard
work God
willing something will break my way and
it happened I think you have to have a
lot of patience and you have to know
that it's not one phone call that it's
many phone calls that you'll be making
that you'll come back to the same people
over and over and over again it's uh
it's a matter of getting people
comfortable with you of getting them on
your side so instead of thinking that
you're going out to raise money you have
to think that you're going out to woo
people to bring them into your Camp to
make them part of your support system to
just get their enthusiasm for your
project and you know if the money isn't
forthcoming immediately that doesn't
mean it's not going to come in the long
run and it doesn't mean that they're not
going to be able to help you in some
other way so I think it's almost like
Gathering your tribe around your project
getting people who see your passion and
believe in you so I think that's the
attitude you have to go in with Armondo
Montelongo I had not
met I didn't even really know about him
because Brian never really spoke to me
about him um he kind of said it vaguely
initially when we were packaging This
Together uh he said oh I work for this
guy um who's really successful in real
estate um and that that was about the
extent of my knowledge of Armand
Montelongo when I was packaging this
together because Brian had come out to
Hollywood and together we were sort of
taking meetings with a lot of production
houses and Studios trying to sell this
story um I put a package together
business plan budget all that
stuff and when we went to these
meetings it was very difficult because
he or
Brian
um stutters a little bit and I think a
lot of people thought that he was always
nervous in the meetings and they were
like calm down calm down and he wasn't
nervous he just has a slight stutter
sometimes you know and obviously if he's
nervous it gets worse um but so a lot of
the meetings had these hiccups because
they all thought that he was nervous and
and being the director you know or
pursuing the the firsttime director of
his project that he wrote
that made investors a little hesitant of
like this guy's not confident enough to
direct and he was he's extremely
confident but he had this one you know
physical trait that kind of perceived
him differently
and also there was the aspect of where
every person that we met with would say
well because in our business plan all
the leads that we had already Walter
Perez Jeremy Ray Valdez myself and
Fernando Romero attached so we had them
in the business plan and they're all
Latino so when any investor looked at
that business plan they didn't really
see any white faces familiar faces they
just saw a lot of brown faces and that
was another reason why they were very
hesitant because they were
like can't you make one of them Latino
and maybe the other three you know like
leave the girl as Latina and maybe the
three guys are
all not on Latino and that happened a
lot so we just kept going and it was
very heartbreaking because uh you know
Brian was out here um he has his own
family he has two kids and a wife back
in San Antonio so he was apart from them
and he was out here and he kept hearing
this you know constant like change your
characters maybe we need another
director because you don't seem like
you're you know confident enough person
to direct this film so those were the
obstacles that we faced
and we just did our best to try and
educate
ourselves
eventually we went and met one of the
directors that I worked with on banded
brothers and The Mentalist David Nutter
and he gave us some great advice Brian
had great editing skills and he told
Brian that Brian should edit a Sizzle
trailer of his film from clips of other
movies so he should take clips of other
movies that are thematic to what he
wants Mission Park to be and fortunately
for Brian all the actors who were
attached to the project Fernanda Walter
Jeremy and myself had work that he could
you know extract scenes from so he
pieced this amazing trailer with us in
it and it looks like the
film it was
brilliant finally
he saw or
Armando saw that Brian was was really
putting in the effort to get this
project made and I met with Armando
finally so I think he was like wow this
project and these guys are really
serious so he read the script finally I
think after two years of Brian trying to
get him to read the script I only took
one year armanda took two years to read
the script and he loved
it and I think after that Brian showed
him the trailer
that he had made that David Nutter
recommended he make and Armando thought
that we had made the film
already and he felt like what I missed
the boat on this one and he hadn't Brown
was just very clever on making the
trailer and that sort of is what
kickstarted Armando into joining the
team and and he's been an amazing
supporter I mean he's our sole investor
one man uh and we always
believed that one person would come and
believe in this project the way we did
and that was
Armando I've had conversations where
they someone goes I have someone who
wants to put money in movies but they
they're they're Pro NRA very political
so you has to make sure there's guns in
the film in some positive way that's
sort of the Edwood conversation you know
it's like oh the film is going to end
with a big
explosion but the film ends with this
not anymore also I got a nephew not a
bright boy but something tells me be a
hell of you have these constraints on it
um the sort of the best way to preface
the conversation I think is If someone
knows someone who has access to money or
knows people who have access to money um
is to say to that person okay here's
what I need I need this much money
here's the investment agreement or
whatever it is and you have these people
if you can get these people to come in
and sign the line which is dotted
and make this film a go film I'll give
you 10% of the budget as your fee and
I'll make you an executive producer
you'll be an executive producer and when
the cash hits our account and clears the
first check is going to be to you so if
we're raising $200,000 the first check
is going to be to you for $20,000 for
finding the money and that's a good way
of approaching it
because a lot of these deals are done
through social means I mean film is not
a smart Financial investment is not a
lot of return you don't do it because
it's going to make money you do it
because it's fun because it's cool you
do it because you like movies you do it
because you like the people involved you
believe in the dream you you do it
because you know that if no one had
invested in Darren rowski or Quenton
Tarantino in the beginning we'd have we
wouldn't have Black Swan or Pulp Fiction
you do it for those reasons
so if you takes it involves being that
politician again taking someone to
dinner and buying them drinks and saying
the right things and making sure you're
fit and I think there's only so much of
a show you want to put on and so many
compromises you want to make before it's
silly but if you have a buffer someone
who knows that person and gets along
with them already they're
friends having them have an incentive to
get the deal done to maybe take that
dinner one with you one without you and
sort of be the social buffer and stay in
the situation and help work it out it's
not a bad way to go and it's not
dishonest because you know it is you're
being hon about what you want we want
this money but this person's involved in
the process and they can make a little
coin off of it it's not a bad way to go
the budget was about 120 and we started
out looking to make it for 100 yeah so I
had this idea I had worked with a
Scottish producer who I knew had
$100,000 to put into a movie and he had
said to me he'd offer $100,000 to three
filmmakers to make movies and they had
all said well can I use that to raise
more money and he had said no you have
to make it for 100,000 and he said it
really blew me away that then they just
passed on it you know and like I just
stored that story in my head and when I
had finished writing obsidia I said to
you know we said okay let's hit him up
for the $100,000 and let's make this
movie for $100,000 and so I at that
point we sought a line producer to make
a budget because we said okay we want to
go to this guy this possible investor
and be able to say to him here's the
scripts you know we want the $100,000
that you offered to three other
filmmakers and they turned you down
we're going to make a movie for $100,000
and here's the budget and here's how
we're going to do it you know here's the
schedule and here's like everything and
we're going to make this movie for
100,000 and so um we then sought a line
producer on Craigslist to do our budget
for us I put a lovely ad on Craigslist I
met a lot of different line producers
and one of them was Matt medin who came
on board to uh to to do that and he was
like I can make a budget for $100,000 a
bunch of them just said you cannot make
this movie for $100,000 but so we
started really with that thing of
budgeting the movie like how do we make
this movie for that amount you know
there's two ways to approach a budget
one is sort of like how much does
everything cost and then add it up and
see what it is and the other way is how
do we make this movie possible for that
amount and so you know then we had to
get real you know to make the movie for
$100,000 we had to lose some things from
the script you know so and and change
things you know in the original script
that he had you know there was like
animal like a cat that was like a sort
of character in the movie there was a
little kid you know there was like you
know so there was things like that that
was just sort of like you know this is
going to make it you know these are
things that are not going to be possible
on this budget and I was absolutely
obsessed with this has to be doable it
has to be realistic on this budget I
don't want to be making a movie that's
like over ambitious for the price
because I know that's like a short you
know ticket to failure so we were sort
of we worked and worked on the script as
well and like I cut
locations um for instance uh after the
main couple go on their date there was a
lovely scene in a cafe or restaurant
instead I made it at his house you know
so it's things like that so it's just
like getting creative with the script to
make it doable for 100,000 um during the
process of meeting the line producers I
also met one young man called Ken Morris
uh who was um just really lovely and
super enthusiastic about the project he
was just out of University so we felt
like he probably didn't have um the
necessary experience to like be the
producer you know like be a producer on
the film but it ended up the the
producer that we the investor that we'
initially um hoped to get the 100,000
from uh it ended up he wanted to invest
some money in it but he situation had
changed for him and he didn't want to
invest as much as 100,000 and he did
love the project and became very you
know uh involved with it and and was
very involved in the development of it
but he then didn't have the money to put
up for it and so suddenly we were like
oh my God what are we going to do who
are we going to get the money from and
Ken Morris this young uh guy who I'd met
as a possible line producer you know he
was and I just said like let's keep him
involved and you know he's terrific
young man suddenly you know he said I
think I think perhaps I can get the
money and he actually brought in a large
part of the money and then we kicked in
and then we kicked in too the rest like
I think actually our budget when we
finally when we went to production had
already moved up to about 105 or
something you know and then um and then
and continue to move up so it did it it
was sort of like over budget the shoot
wasn't over budget the shoot stayed
completely within the the the the thing
that we hadn't fully budgeted for
realistically was was post you know in
particular sound which was more
expensive than we had anticipated yeah
because of wind in the desert or well
that did play a factor and it did there
was some wind issues didn't hear them
but I I noticed it was very clean there
was some wind issues but we that did
play a factor in it but because we paid
for a decent sound mix I mean we had a
great sound record on set a sound mixer
Tom curlyy who was phenomenal and he did
a great job and he got us Great Sound um
but then I think you know and it's just
that thing like you know for a film to
work it need the sound does need to be
half decent and we did so we did end up
spending a decent bit of money to get a
proper professional sound mix done you
know and I think a lot of those Tiny But
movies don't do that and and also as
well this is because it is expensive
and it
does uh kill them and and you know it
can kill them we wer we went on that as
much as we should have been from the
get-go again it gets into building your
team earlier as opposed to waiting till
the last minute we if we'd have built
that team a little earlier I think we
probably would have been in a position
where we could have negotiated a better
price with the sound yeah with the
people that we chose but but they saw
that we were behind the eightball so
they basically you know pushed their
agenda more than
ours all I remembers meeting a uh a
former NYU graduate and he said oh you
should meet this guy because he and even
at that time I was kind of worried about
being
um dependent on a studio or a networker
giving me a job I mean it already felt
enormously competitive all I had was an
was my thesis film you know I wasn't
going to get picked to
direct aliens or something it wasn't
that that wasn't going to happen and I
started to think very I started to think
independently I was like well look I've
got to demonstrate that I know that I
demonstrate that I can make a feature
film to myself and anybody else so I
can't wait on somebody giving me a fe
money for a feature film so I got to
figure out a way to do this and he was
like oh well that's cuz so many people
are like well you know Studio I'm only
going to make $50 million movies and I'm
going to spend the next 10 years in
development and then it's like I never
had the patience for that I was and I
guess I was a bit of a pessimist I was
like look I'm going to have to do this
somehow my on my own or a realist yeah
or yeah just be or yeah and I just was
like okay how do I do that well I don't
have the money but this guy did this guy
had the money at least a monum of money
right on the credit card and he had the
the will his name was his name was Mick
weinhof and and Mick was like I'm going
to do this and and I think he was
suffering from the same sort of fatigue
that all of us he had been coming as an
actor he had been trying to get parts
and stuff and had got had some success
but he was getting frustrated like this
is going nowhere how no one's going to
give me a lead part so I need to come up
with a way where I can get a lead part
well I'll produce a movie I'll pay for
it that'll guarantee me this lead part
and he had the strength and the um he
had the smarts enough to put the thing
together he's the one who got d Danny
bonuchi but he still needed someone like
myself to write and direct it and bring
more cast and more crew and and bring
that and so it was a good you know it
was a classic collaboration he had these
resources but he needed this he needed
this from me and I needed someone to
bankroll my first feature so that's
that's how that happened I think working
on credit cards is D I don't want to I'm
not going to advise that because that's
really scary that said if I had a credit
card that had no interest for a
year and I knew I could make that money
back in a year with a reasonable amount
of certainty I might not not do
that um but I think it's always better
to go with with positive cash I have
done this I have close an IRA to fund a
part of a film I have done that so um I
it's like saying know the whole thing is
uh you miss all the shots you don't take
well you you also don't you also don't
have all the films you don't make like
how long are you g to be dead like
here's your death here's
forever well I die with all this money
yeah but you could have made another
film you know those films are made over
here they're not made here so and I
think you know as I get older and takes
me three or four years to make a movie I
get very aware of time you know how many
more films do I have before I'm too old
to lift the camera or before I get
mocked so you just sold all the Levitz
Furniture stock and you said yeah you
make you make it but again I think like
I know these filmmakers out of New York
and they make a film every a couple
years and they they made their they made
one on 16 they they raised a lot of
money and they made one on super 16 a
few years ago they made the next one for
like 40 Grand they wanted to make
another one they didn't have access to
money this they didn't have the they
hadn't gotten money from this yet they
hadn't got money this yet they were in a
place where they didn't have money they
didn't want they didn't want a crowdfund
so they found a way to make a film for a
th000 bucks they may sh on a 5D and one
of the one of them acted in it as the
lead and they got another actor they new
New York to play the other lead and they
went back to their Hometown and they
shot in their parents restaurant their
parents played her parents and these
people that they knew and they shot this
very a crew of like a very small crew
with you know lavaliers and little Mike
pack and crew of two and they shot this
thing for under
$1,000 and it's a really good movie and
it's a really well done movie it's a
very well acted film they knew exactly
where where to bring in real actors and
where to like you know let people be
themselves um using these locations that
they could control and and they took
good time and it's and they shot on
again they use Labs used the zoom and a
5D and the film looks and sounds great
it's a really good movie for a thousand
bucks so I think you often you just you
find a way to do it is really how it
works um maybe their next film they
crowdfunder maybe their next film fail
do this but you kind of have to unless
you have a reliable source of Revenue or
you have trust fund you really have to
kind of alternate how you raise money
for movies and you have to kind of pick
the right way of raising money for that
film or pick the film based on the money
you have access to at that time I would
definitely have to say the first one
she's going to have it which cost
$175,000 cuz that
was my debut film as far as a feature
film as feature films go and people
think that I did that film right after
film school there was a
4year period between me finishing NYU
and she's going to have it coming out so
it was
not like that and then another one would
be uh Malcolm X we ran out of money and
they had
to go get some money
too does it ever get
easier what's
easy what easy I mean if it was easy you
know I wouldn't be I wouldn't have
launched a Kickstarter campaign this
this we're in day five so
uh this a tough business you you know
that's and I
really and E can can tell you he's one
of my students and every time I'm here
in La he helps
me but I do not try to sugar Coke things
all to my
students and uh it would be a great
disservice to them if I did that so I
let them
know
you know this this is no guarantee it's
going to happen for
you for so for my first film 10 miles
per hour we financed it in large part
with credit cards uh both Josh and I
said we can't find any sponsors we don't
know where the money's at um put a lot
of work into that put a lot of energy
into trying to get you know other people
to help fund the film and and really
blanked out so we just took our credit
cards and financed it and we got to a
point in the process where we needed to
tap into a little a little bit of our
retirement savings which was nice that I
had that available CU I know you know
some people don't and and it's
interesting because people are always so
afraid to spend their retirement but I
found it really a freeing activity like
ultimately it's been a great way to use
that investment to ultimately further my
life and my experiences which I think
should be the right thing so that was 10
miles pror we it was tough we took a lot
of our own you know money and just
dumped it in and said we've got to get
this thing done and we've got to make it
and and uh and put it out to the
market um eventually over the course of
time with 10 miles PR the money that we
did Hard Cash that we actually spent on
our our uh credit cards and retirement
was was returned to us so that was that
was cool all the sweat i' would say
probably never totally got paid back um
but it's nice to know that the film is
still generating some Revenue almost you
know um eight years or so after its
release so it's pretty cool second film
10 yards um we were actually at this
point in time able to start looking at
um some sponsorships and we were able to
close some sponsorships but it was
pretty limited I mean we were talking 15
to $220,000 somewhere in that range of
cash that we raised but it took quite a
bit edge off with making the film um by
this time I we had some of the camera
equipment already you know we' invested
some of that early money and into sort
of building a program uh there was also
some additional cash that was put in as
sort of investment from from an
individual and so that was again we were
in a place where all of a sudden there
was a little bit of money but we didn't
quite have enough money to really round
it out get the film done and then have
enough left over for a launch um so we
were you know burning all of the cash on
production which is probably the biggest
challenge I think filmmakers face is we
get a little bit of money some somehow
or another you know and we blow it all
to make this film and then you're in
this situation where okay the film made
a lot of times people blow it all before
they edit it you know and then that's a
really difficult position to be in so I
think you know you really got to think
that through and div it up and let
people know early off that it's going to
be a long time before they probably see
money so with 10 yards unfortunately
because we were putting all all of the
money that we we received from these
sponsorships and this individual we were
putting it all into you know making the
film and and trying to market the film
we ended up spending more money of our
own and getting a little bit further
into debt so after that film I was in a
I was in a tough Place couldn't figure
out how to make any money off that film
it just it was just my sophomore slump
and it was a really tough one so moving
on to my third
film um Ride The Divide I you know I'm
figuring things out I'm realizing okay
sponsorships man I know I can make these
work better by this time I had two
examples and I could sort of paint 10
yards as a success to the sponsors when
we went out to try to get money so I
worked with Mike Dion on this and we
went out and we actually raised quite a
bit of sponsorship money I'd say
um I want to say around 50 Grand and
then there was again private investment
put into that film um probably equal
amount in in private investment so we
actually had a nice chunk of money um
that was put in that film as we got
closer to release there was another
little bit of investment that came in to
finish it up um and so that film was
great because it was in we were in a
situation where there was there was
always cash but we were very smart about
not overspending cash and
really most of that money is going into
production not really paying people it's
going into travel it's going into you
know the aspects of post- production
where you really need to hire expertise
like sound and color correction um and
just finishing the film and getting it
really solid you know being able to buy
product and things like that so you can
sell the film so we had a great
situation where when that film was done
there wasn't too much of that you know
money to pay back there was a little bit
I think there was a little bit of debt
still debt SL investment that was put
into that film um um and so we were able
to pay that off quickly because the film
was was really successful and had you
know was by far my my most U most most
profitable film so far that I've worked
on and uh it's you know it continues to
do really well and that that film
released three or four years ago I think
about three three and a half um and it's
still doing really well so it's pretty
cool cuz it's like we passed that Mark
now it it creates a revenue stream that
I try to figure out ways not to use but
um you know inevitably I I do at times
to to make sure I further further my
career I keep reinvesting in my films so
moving on to the fourth film uh that was
where the Yellowstone goes which was
made in tandem with another film called
reveal the path and I have some
ownership in each of those films so we
can kind of talk about both of those
together
essentially where the Yellowstone goes
was able to raise about
75,000 in sponsorship money money this
is coming from um basically corporate
Brands uh or n or nonprofit one
nonprofit for for corporate Brands and
they put money into the film because
they liked the message that's that told
we found ways to create some ancillary
content and just kind of help you know
use the film to drive at some of the
messages they're trying to communicate
and reach the same audience um then we
were also able to raise some crowd
funding money around the time that film
was finished and ready for Market which
helped it go to market we took all the
money we raised in crowd funding and put
it into pushing the film further out
there and getting more screening set up
um which is scary to do CU you're like
you work so hard and you're like oh all
of a sudden we got $32,000 in the bank
and you're like this is great it's
payday but but we look at it and we're
like it's not you just it's almost like
you keep putting this money in there one
way or another um and so that film's
done also done really well and it was
nice that the minute it went to market
for the most part I mean it took a
there's a little bit maybe to pay off
for like a month or two to but like it
was like basically instant instant money
that we were able to give back to the
the partners and the
creators um at the same time we made
reveal the path which got um it got more
investment than sponsorship it got a
little bit of sponsorship not as much as
where the Yellowstone goes I can't say
the exact figure but you know it was
less than
75,000 and but it got also quite a bit
of infusion of investment it was a
highly intensive like travel around the
world film where we went to five
different countries and shot and so we
were dealing with uh a more expensive
film than where the Yellowstone goes and
so in the end that film went to Market
and had a lot of money to pay back and
we're still at a point we're paying that
film back so that's just kind of an
example of how you got to weigh all
these things and be careful if you can
if you can raise some money and really
be careful about how you spend that
money um and then you know try to get
partners Creator create creative
Partners on board who will benefit later
uh you can get to that that money coming
in quicker um um and then finally Walter
um Walter was is a very lowbudget film
um a lot of sweat for both my wife and I
it was it's kind of a collaborative
project where we came together as we
were getting married and made this film
um and so we had some investment um
about $35,000 in investment to make the
film we used that cash and then raised
25,000 for its release um and put a lot
of sweat and got some some friends to
help us out so we've got our again our
creative partner strategy and uh we're
now uh releasing it with not too much
debt we have some investment but that's
part of the it kind of balances out with
the creative Partners as well so I mean
we hope that by next year or you know
early next year depending on how fast we
push the release because we we've been
thinking about kind of taking time but
we hope that film is paying everybody
back you know soon so it seems to be
working you know but it's and keep in
mind that that Walter actually started
before where the Yellowstone goes so it
kind of kind of fits in there and and
ultimately where the Yellowstone goes Le
has led to another film a whole river
series and one of the sponsors that was
involved with that um doubled their
commitment to the next film and intends
to do a series of more River films with
us so we're doing sort of the same sort
of strategy where we keep a documentary
that is essentially low cach budget High
sweat budget and in the end has a uh has
a quicker payout for the people that are
involved that are committed and take the
chance well the first time was uh peace
together you know I was from the
community that I from Alton you know
little bits and pieces here and there
and then um I teamed up with the
production company in Los Angeles and
they brought they brought on they came
on board as co-
financers and that happened over about a
year and it excuse me about a year and a
half um that was unique in that sense it
took a long time but you know that
really was fell in you know many
different resources I think I think at
the end of the day we had like 22 people
who had equity in the movie on the
second film it was financed by one
person it was the story he wanted to
tell he was the executive producer and
it's what you know it was a vanity
project and I don't mean that in a
negative way he had the money he wanted
to tell the story and he hired people to
do it and that you know and I was one of
those people he hired I didn't have to
raise any money and um I got to be
creative and
everything uh the third film joint body
was a similar deal only three people I
did dealing with the guy that gets out
of jail um again Alton some Alton equity
and then some Equity from the East
Coast um and then she loves me not which
is what I just finished was sort of
along the lines of of the cover up was
end financed by one individual but it
was more alteris in the sense of he was
living in this beautiful home that has a
lot of history in the
community and he saw it as an
opportunity to blend sort of the history
of the home from from the 20s and show
how it's evolved into now and and um so
he approached me and said I want to do
this film in the house and are you
willing to talk to me about what a
potential story so it was much more um
organic and how that grew but I was
still given guidelines it's not like um
I approached him and said hey I want to
make a movie in in this beautiful state
the initial part um as soon as I decided
to make the film I reached out to um two
people two women I had worked with
extensively over the years documentary
filmmakers and um Kobe Atlas and Kira
Thompson um Kira just W to uh Emy she is
a producer supervising producer on The
Voice and Kobe was is amazing
um vice president of uh PBS for
programming used to be and now she's
doing a gazillion other things so I
reached out to them um and they helped
me um kind of get my footing and I had
raised I had actually raised enough
money um I'd raise $60,000 for another
documentary and when I wanted to do this
one I just asked our donors if they
would be willing to let me transfer it
and then I reached out to my very first
boss Teresa toini Coleman and um asked
her if I could run the film through her
nonprofit which is what I'd done with my
short documentary and as soon as she
heard about the the subject she was like
I want to be involved I want to work on
it and it just so happened that she had
the exact same amount of money um that
she needed to invest into a a film
because it's a nonprofit so it needed to
be kind of
recirculated and so we had just enough
for a super bare Bon shoot I mean it was
we were paying people $100 a day um but
luckily since I'd worked in the film
industry most of my life people were I
could get great people um and they were
doing it as a favor to me and so we
actually did run out of money on the
shoot and I had to put in some of my own
life savings just a bit but some and
then afterwards um we came back we cut
together this 23 minute fundraising
trailer and you know I knew it wouldn't
be easy but I thought okay you know
we'll apply to some foundations and some
religious instit organizations and
government institutions and you know
Spanish tourism and all these places but
of course that was right when the crash
happened and Spain was just a mess I
mean there was just no money there
whatsoever and we got turned down right
left and Center um all the traditional
funding sources except for one Grant we
got from um Pacific Pioneer fund and
then we did we also got um two small
grants from American pilgrims but then
everything else um was all raised from
individuals and I what happened was
after about a year and a half of trying
the traditional funding I
realized I wasn't it wasn't going to
happen that way and I it pretty much
turned into me asking everyone I'd ever
met um or new for money and here was a
case though I really had to kind of do
some work around my issues with money
and asking for money and asking for help
um and what was really neat and really
extremely touching was my high school
classmates um really turned out and it
was they funded almost 40% of the post
um of of that phase of once I needed to
um finish the film and Incredibly
supportive people I hadn't seen in 30
years sending in Thousand checks and um
and then I had four out of five of my um
funding producers I had gone to high
school with and I was also really the um
one of my classmates um is Dan Brown who
did The Da Vinci Code and he and his
wife stepped in and funded the whole
online process once they saw the rough
cut and they were just um really touched
and believed in the project and if it
wasn't for Dan and bl I might still be
fundraising advice to other filmmakers
doing the same not only just getting
over the hurdle of having to ask for
help which is a big thing we all you
know DIY we want to do this ourselves no
we don't need anyone's help but ways to
do it ways to get over that yeah um
there's a couple of books I really
recommend um I think kind of working on
your internal stuff with with money is
is the first step um I think pretty much
everything we do really is from from the
inside out um there's a book called
spiritual economics by Eric butter worth
um the power um the soul of money by Lin
twist and then Lin twist also has um a
CD set fundraising from the heart um and
I think the the biggest thing I would
encourage people is only do things that
you're 110% believe are going to do some
good in the world there has to be
something fueling you more than money
more than um Fame like some really
inherit strong pull for you because it's
just too hard otherwise I mean to to
sustain it but it kind of goes back a
few years we were hoping to make this
movie originally in um I think I first
got together with Joe in 2006 or 2007 we
were hoping to make it in 2008 for2 or3
million do you know that was the goal
like aim high with your budget right and
because you never know you may get lucky
and um you know it was kind of in the
era of squiding the whale and you know
Indie movies you could get made for that
um it wasn't so crazy anyway and we were
getting close to that point we were
getting a great cast because at that
point you're offering some real money I
mean not real money in the sense that we
didn't have it but it's Finance
contingent money um but anyway we were
getting it out to good actors and we
were getting a great cast but the but
then the economy as you well know uh
tanked in the fall of 2008 and there was
no way you could
raise millions or thousands or even
hundreds or tens of dollars for any film
at any budget level for at least six
more months or so um so luckily for me
that happened to coincide with um if you
remember it was also during the election
campaign of 2008 with a side project
that I was doing here in the garage uh
which was uh with another filmmaker who
was staying here for about five months
at least um named dayon gorland another
slam Nance guy and uh he and I were
doing this completely unrelated project
it was about um a Washington based
pundit and originally was a series of
short films then it was a TV pitch and
then we kind of were incubating this
character his name is Martin eisenstat
uh online we gave him a Blog and a
website and he um uh and people in the
media started to believe he was
real and so we uh uh there was a lot of
press about this at the time and it kind
of culminated with Sarah Palin not
knowing that Africa was a country uh or
no not knowing it was a she said it was
a country she really did say but our
character took credit for being the
source of that story anyway MSNBC had
breaking news but they had egg on their
face because he wasn't real and they
were saying he was the source of the
story anyway the long story short New
York Times did a big half-page profile
of us um and the next day we got a book
offer so when presented from a very
prestigious New York publisher for
ouro and so when presented with the
option do you keep not getting paid to
not direct a movie or do you get pay to
write a book one's wife tells you to
write the book and um so we did that Aon
and I wrote this book you know we took a
complete Hiatus off of between us he was
trying to get a feature of his made at
the time as well and um and we wrote the
book we had a great time on the book
tour it was very critically acclaimed it
sold well it uh it was you know very
successful we went back to pitching it's
a TV show and actually came very close
uh to a deal with Ashton coer company
was going to produce it CBS Studios was
behind it it was going to be on Showtime
and then the the deal fell through
because one executive got fired or
something you know and so it was like oh
huh so much for our TV
career but uh my old my previous casting
director from open house Liz Jesy said
you know what why don't we go back to
between us at the end of the day it was
four people in two rooms how hard could
it be let's you know we know how to make
these micro budget movies um let's do
that so she put in a little bit of money
now and came on as a producer um we
raised some money on Facebook then this
is early years of Kickstarter we did a
Kickstarter campaign and um and that was
enough to you know so by the time we had
around 40 or so, 45 something in that
range that was enough to set a start
date I knew we could always make
something at that level and
so uh so we we went back to the agents
managers that we were casting with
originally and said okay well the script
hasn't changed we never rewrote the
script to be a lower budget maybe we
should have but we didn't and um and the
parts are the same so if you liked it
before and your actors liked it before
they're going to like it now um we're
just not paying them really you know
we'll pay them $100 a day and we had
enough to we had enough to to afford
that we didn't have enough to pay the
crew we had enough to feed the actors as
long as they didn't have peanut
allergies because then we couldn't give
them peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
so that's always the first question to
ask um or gluten yeah gluten yeah no
that would have tank but thankfully
actors don't eat I mean it's axiomatic
in this town like actors I mean they
don't eat carbs at all and I don't think
they eat anything I I you know I don't
know how it works with them so you know
feeding them is actually fairly easy but
um sorry uh but yeah we uh and then we
were able to find a crew that was
willing to work for free we said look
we're going to keep raising money you
know and and we were raising money you
know until we didn't need to but um um
but you know if you want to work on this
movie don't expect to get paid if it
happens great but don't expect it and
luckily in La you can find enough really
good crew people that will work on a
movie like this so we had an amazing
cinematographer Nancy shriber who I'd
met at slam Dan who's um an ASC
cinematographer she's only I think like
the third woman that was ever in the ASC
and she she was a DP on visions of Light
which is this great documentary about
cinematographers anyway he's
award-winning filmmaker and um so she
came on board and she was teaching class
at AFI so she brought in a lot of her
students who worked on it and you know a
lot of people just wanted to work with
her and people knew me through slam
dance they saw the actors like oh okay
this is something to to jump in on
anyway and in the end we we did find an
investor that came in for you know
roughly two-thirds of the budget um and
his check only cleared the third to the
last day of shooting but that was enough
time to pay pay the crew at least some
of the crew I still haven't gotten paid
some other people have and um you know
and we finished and it was enough to
finish the film well that first
25,000 it wasn't even that much I think
it was like was 20 in the
end came from a couple individual people
Liz and then two people that were
friends on Facebook but like I one of
them was someone I knew from high school
I hadn't talked to her in you know 20
years at least a lot more than that you
know and another was another Indie
filmmaker I had no idea he had money you
know and would give it to me so you know
just and I was like oh this okay this
kind of crowd sourcing is is working
nicely so like and then Kickstarter was
happening and a friend of mine had done
the kickstarter and he said yeah you
know you can you can raise a good 10
grand or so on there yeah 2010 fall of
2010 we did that so it was it was way
before the whole Veronica Brath you know
raise $2 million because you've got a
movie star oh how hard could it be you
know it's like no $10,000 was a doable
goal and um you know achievable hard
work to get it you know it's not easy um
but you know we did it we and we did
some unique things with it in how we
promoted it but also I put our business
plan I embedded it as a PDF onto the
kickstarter page kind of as a almost a
trojan horse so people wanted to give
substantially more money but do it as an
investment they could find the PDF so
that so what happened was that even
though we only raised about $10,000 on
Kickstarter per se it led to us getting
another 20 or 25,000 kind of ultimately
uh Beyond Kickstarter um you know but
more importantly I mean I always tell
people kickstar it's called Kickstarter
it's not called Kick finisher I mean
it's really there to get the ball
rolling and then how you take it from
there is up to you um but I think the
most important person of all the 84
backers that you know that we found on
Kickstarter you know the most important
person to convince is yourself you know
because it it forces you to you know
this whole process forced me to do a
business plan to do a a pitch video and
and and you know the hardest person to
convince to make a movie is it's always
yourself everyone else you they'll
believe you you know but um but you you
know better especially after it's your
third or fourth film when uh Joel and I
were developing it uh we were constantly
working together so that meant we were
going out to producers we were going out
to investors we were going out to
Casting agents we were going out to
anyone that would read it that could
help us put together our package so the
the challenges that happened were that
we were attaching people that were good
that were you know friends of jeles or
just people who like the script and we
were getting investors that were
interested and investors that really
wanted to make the film and were willing
to option it and put in the time but
because of different reasons they
weren't able to finance it at the end so
you know sometimes production companies
will have a slate of three films that
year and one will go way over budget and
another one will get pushed and you know
there's just there's always different
reasons why financing can fall through
so unfortunately for us that happened on
three different occasions I mean for
some films it happens 10 times 20 times
30 times you know for other films they
get financing they move forward you know
we the third time when we lost
financing um within 48 Hours the
producer that we had attached Taylor
Hart is his name who is uh an incredible
uh producer U very hungry and driven and
getting a lot of projects done now
within 48 Hours of the last time that we
had our financing fall through he found
another production company and they
brought all the money to the table so
with that we were able to start
pre-production the next day so we you
know we had a terrible weekend thinking
the film was once again shut down and on
Monday we were flying out to Savannah
Georgia to shoot the film so it just
every single time you try to get a film
into production or even in a pre
production or get the financing you're
going to find obstacles along the way so
the financing falling through is just
the very first obstacle you always have
an investment packet where you have all
the information and you kind of have
that disclaimer in there and saying you
know what there are better Investments
than indie film if you want to you know
if you want to really invest your money
well put it in commercial real estate I
think it's what you always go back to is
they say well you know I'm no I'll make
sure I get a return on my investment you
say well unfortunately when you're
investing in the Arts the you know the
financial investment can take time to
happen or may never happen or may be
partial you know you can make the terms
as favorable as you want the deal you we
have it so you get 120% of your
investment back before we see a
dime
but you always say is that really why
you're investing you know bring it back
to the fun bring it back to the fact
that this is going to be an adventure
you get to go on set you get to hang out
of parties you go to film festivals and
all these things and you get be part of
the fund uh we have an exec producer on
favor who put in some money
and she knew she wasn't going to get it
back um or would be a long time but she
she you know she loved the script and
she you know loved Patrick and she's
been a huge advocate for us still and
involved she's gotten very involved in
the film and she came down to the Q and
she started putting money into other
films because she really just likes the
dream she's like I'd rather be a patron
of the art and I'll get these films made
and go see these things in front of
audiences and just enjoy enabling
artists then you know worrying about
whether I get you know return on my you
know a few thousand dollars it's not
investing big sums of money but but I
mean it's definitely helpful I'll tell
you what dance is easy it's harder to
raise a million than 25
million
why because there's just this mindset
that a film to cost million
dollars there's very
little want to see or very little return
of investment in a film that's small
there's a prejudice
against films under 1 million when I was
in school um so I did like I did a
degree like a college degree and then
after that I went to this place in
Canada called the Canadian Film Center
and it's like our version of the AFI
basically so I I was writing it there as
as well um this script and you're they
give you the means to like make a little
short so I made a little short about it
as well that no one will ever see
hopefully ever it's terrible um it's
actually it's all right but um so I I
did that and then with that short I
approached um a producer in in Toronto
that I was interested in that I had
actually worked with as an actress who
was doing really really interesting work
and then uh yeah and then we went to um
the funders with our Collective
experiences that short and an outline
and then they give us a little bit of
money to write the first draft and then
once we were in that once we had the
first draft then we actually got like a
little more substantial money um for
sort of each subsequent draft so yeah I
mean Canada's really great that way
because we have a government um system
set up to support the Arts and if you
can get into that system it's also like
highly debated system by multiple
filmmakers as you can understand who are
living in Canada because you know if you
don't get funding it you're sort of left
out but if you end up being a part of
that that
system um then you can you know you can
you can make an okay living for I mean
you are getting yeah they're they
acknowledge that you know you have to
take time off of your like teaching job
or your you know your side projects or
whatever to concentrate on the script so
there there is that ability yeah
Progressive in any ways yeah absolutely
well they do that in Europe as well I
mean America is is you know we're cap
the capitalistic Society here so and
that you know that works a lot for film
as well so there's a lot of problems in
the Canadian system but but there is
that kind of belief that there's like
True Value in culture in supporting you
know Arts which is great this lab at at
Tiff at the Toronto uh International
Film Festival had a screenwriting uh
screenwriting lab like it's similar to
how like dances but it was the inaugural
year and I applied with this script and
um it was a workshop with like another
yet another story editor um mine was
from like Sweden we would Skype it was
like this very kind of interesting
experience where she was completely out
of kind of the the the group of
screenwriters and writers and filmmakers
that I was used to so she was a totally
fresh eyes on this project and that
script uh won like my script won the
audience award for that so it was
awarded something and then we kind of
fast-tracked to um production so that's
when we um were able to approach the
Canadian um funding bodies and ask for
money for for making the film and that's
a very long process I don't know if it's
boring or not but it's it you know there
were a lot of in putting all the
financing together for this film um um
it was it was really tricky it was just
really really tricky because of the
budget level and because of certain kind
of funding that we got because there's
different funding agencies in Canada so
we actually had to shoot some of it in a
certain geographical location in Canada
so all the Interiors are done in Ontario
and the exteriors are Japan and and BC
oh okay so that's like that would be
like the equivalent of like doing only
Interiors in New York and exteriors in
LA or something I mean it's like that
far apart between like cbury Ontario and
and BC and then obviously
Japan so yeah and then like the you know
the leadup to actually the day of
shooting there was like three intense
months of prep six months of of soft
prep like location uh uh scouting and
everything it I mean that was like a
that's a blur like that's it was so
intense during those those final 3
months that we were all getting sick and
we were all like it was like but it was
but it was amazing it's thrilling cuz
you know what's going to happen it took
so long because we knew we had to do it
at a certain budget and it's still
incredibly low budget compared to what
is out there like we're at like $1.2
million but they're not they don't give
that to you just for kind of nothing so
you really have to be prepared and ready
to go and um when it all happens so yeah
it it was a huge learning curve I mean
yeah it was it was uh very challenging
but very thrilling I think if you're in
in fil you probably love problem solving
you probably have that kind of mind and
I I do like it feels creative to me to
like be given a challenge or an obstacle
and just be like I got this I can do
this analytical thinking towards
figuring it out and you just do you just
put the pieces of the puzzle together
the funny thing is um the funding
agencies were pretty hands off I've
heard other stories but they were pretty
hands-off with us in terms
of content they just wanted to see the
drafts and know that we were continuing
along and and in terms of like creative
input they didn't give a ton of that so
we were kind of like really really lucky
um I haven't heard that as being
necessarily the case
for you know other other people um but
again because it's like a government
funding they're not really necessarily
creatives that are funding it always
they're it's a bureaucracy it's like
it's a where it's a self like country
that finances art so they're you know
making sure that you're getting your
drafts in on time and that kind of
bureaucracy but they're not necessarily
like commenting on the content like they
might a little bit but it it's not hard
and fast yeah so they're not saying you
know what can we make sweet PE more this
likeable and all that yeah well I mean
but that's still like there was a lot of
input on the script process like all
along the way um regardless of the
funding agencies because you're just
showing it to other people and you're
just or you're sending it to you know
like the like the the screenwriting lab
or you know we sent it to a Tribeca lab
you know early on in the process too so
people are giving feedback in that sense
and yeah there's definitely I have
stories of like that make you know sweet
pee more likable and you know sexy and
or I don't know anything but yeah you
just have to kind of know what your um
know what the story is you're you're
telling and try to stay as flexible and
open to other people's thoughts but then
ultimately like know the best decision
to be made for the film that you trying
to make cuz that's why they're giving
you the money is to hear your point of
view you know it's a big process trying
to find money because it's everyone who
wants to give you money has an opinion
about a script as they should because
they're giving you money and
um so there's that and
then I don't know people like it they
don't like it I was living in a
different country I had to come to
America I had to come to Los Angeles to
kind of focus on that so that was like
even a year after of trying to kind of
have meetings and go back and forth and
I mean my last moment took four years to
be able to make and it's it's not an
uncommon story among among filmmakers um
so this has been a couple of years but
then I did a really big script change
and which I think
is way better it's not a comedy anymore
it's kind of a movie about something
it's got funny parts in it but it's not
comedy and
so you know I I was thinking about this
too and I was thinking about how great
crowd how a great the an effective
crowdfunding can be because sometimes
you write a script and four years pass
and you become a different person in
that time and none of those things
really make sense and then okay you
could go back and rewrite but there's
something if you have an idea and you
can have the immediacy of making it in
that time it becomes a full thought
instead of like this constant broken up
where you have to become like you have
to put down your artist hat and you have
to put on your producer hat and you have
to go in and you have to get money and
like that's fine it's all part of the
thing but it's distracting from you each
other so once you you can never get back
on the role and
so it takes a while it takes a while it
takes much longer than people think and
you know in the meantime like hopefully
get some other jobs to pay for your life
and
um and you keep going we shot she's
going to have it in
1985 we were doing Kickstarter before
there was
Kickstarter we just didn't have the
technology I was making phone calls
making personal
visits writing
letters
so we did everything except social media
was social media was not around it you
know I I never would have launched a
campaign for six
figures uh if I hadn't spent two years
building an online audience with a
website um so you know it's one of those
10 years to an overnight success kind of
thing where all the work you've put in
in the back you
hope um you know helps you do this thing
that was the most ambitious thing I'd
ever done in my life as far as you know
a Kickstarter campaign is All or nothing
and when you hit launch and it says
$115,000 and it says 0 and0 you know
from here to there is a long way to go
um but I felt like I had done everything
in my power over the last couple of
years years to to build a website and I
felt like enough people knew who I was
and that it was a strong enough project
with some external validation from from
ifp and from Lincoln Center um that it
was you know I I I felt like if I failed
that I would have done everything I
possibly could and then I wouldn't feel
bad about it um so you know the main
thing was was building an audience and
the way that I went about it is
different than a lot of people will as
far as you know I was talking about the
craft of film making and the behind the
scenes stuff um as opposed to just this
one particular project but ultimately I
think it comes down to that approach of
saying you know Kickstarter Indiegogo
these things aren't magic you know
you you can make a great video um and
But ultimately you have to have a
feeling of you've been working on this
for a long time and people know who you
are and have are invested in your
success so it's not you know I think the
the Kickstarter campaigns that don't
succeed a lot of the times are ones
where people you know saw somebody else
doing this and thought oh well I can do
that too and they didn't really
understand the amount of work that the
other people did the successful
campaigns did not only during their
campaign but before it when a lot of
that work
happens I thought about it um I felt I
feel to successful I I really believe in
crowdfunding in a lot of ways I feel for
it to be most successful you need to
have the support of everyone involved
and for me David's been Inc like Beyond
supportive like overwhelmingly
supportive of the project but he wasn't
a producer on the film um he you know he
would say this too he's not he wasn't
interested in the process he wanted to
let me go make it and I sort of felt to
run a successful crowdsourcing campaign
for it it would have needed his
involvement because I felt it would have
been sort of disingenuine to be the way
to run a successful campaign would have
been like hey sederis fans you want to
see a Sedaris movie and it felt would
sort of I didn't feel comfortable asking
him maybe he would have helped me and
done a video I'm not sure but I it felt
wrong to ask him you know for me and I
felt without his support it felt sort of
wrong to run a campaign for it now that
there's a finished film if I had we you
know we've closed distribution so I but
if I was doing a self-d distribution I
would consider it now that there's a
finished film and now that I have
interviews with David and elements I can
use um with his permission of course but
but I feel like it's each each projects
its own and some projects are meant to
be crowdfunded and and this one just
wasn't wasn't one of them I didn't feel
like I could engage the community in the
right way and also we had some actors
attached but they ended up not being the
actors in the final film and I felt like
we would have needed to utilize them but
I felt uncomfortable with that because I
didn't have a working relationship with
them yet and they were you know slightly
bigger names than what ended up in the
movie Just by the nature of whoever at
the time I cast them they weren't bigger
names and they got bigger names and got
too busy to be in the film and I ended
up with a cast I could have only dreamed
of having anyway so I'm I'm thrilled
about that but it felt strange to bring
them involved it just didn't feel like I
could do it the right way and I feel
like when I look at the really
successful crowd
crowd campaigns sure there's some
outliers that go into the three and
$400,000 but I really feel like the most
ambitious you really should get you know
is to expect is at the most you know 100
you know I feel like even the Canyons I
think they ended up going to like 130
but you have Paul Shader and Brett
Easton Ellis who each have massive loyal
decades long fan bases and even then
they pushed a lot on that campaign and
you know they hit which is incredible
amount of money but that still wasn't
enough for me to make the film so I also
felt uncomfortable
going out there and being like give me
$100,000 and maybe I'll be able to find
the other however much we need it it it
just felt wrong for this project but I
hope I can do something one day that I
can make cheaply enough you know this
movie had to be shot on location it had
30 speaking Parts it had you know a
different location every day all
exteriors just had things that naturally
made it expensive um and uh but I hope
to do something if I did something small
if I did a movie I could shoot on my own
and with minimal crew and minimal
locations and here in Los Angeles I
would I would consider um doing
crowdsourcing that way well I've um been
lucky to find private money to fund my
documentaries but there are more
traditional
sources and that's generally teaming up
with either a production company or a
network you know it's a traditional way
you go and you pitch a network HBO what
have you and they're going to go into
business with you that's ideally the way
you do things that's not easy either so
these other avenues have come along
grants I've never done because you need
the patience of Job to do that that
takes forever and you and the money's
coming in in very small amounts it's
possible I have a good friend doing a
documentary now on WC handy and she
received money a grant money and so
she's you know she's been filming as she
goes along so it is
possible um the
crowdfunding is also difficult I've had
three friends who have successfully
funded at various price points up from
35,000 up to 200,000
that's very rare but it's it's doable on
on uh in on Kickstarter or
Indiegogo
um and then you know there's there's uh
so there there's private individuals
that's another form that I found uh
that's also difficult but it's it it it
does cut through a lot of the back and
forth with grants or networks or what
have you so it's that's always the
number one question and and the toughest
thing is how do you get the money to
make these these things so you know it's
it's really going out to the marketplace
and finding out they're going to say
well what's in it for them can they make
money off this Enterprise it's it's are
they going to be able to see the return
on their Dollar on their investment um
so that's why you consider these things
when you're picking your topics you know
you want to you want to look at the
marketplace and say is there room in the
market for this documentary is there has
there been competition on this subject
if so uh is there room for one more if
not is was there a reason nobody wanted
to do this topic so you're going to look
at all that you know as you go into
funding but it's always the most
difficult thing there are new ways to do
it I wouldn't say no to the
crowdsourcing because if you have a good
pitch and you have a good idea and you
maybe only need funds to either get
started or finish maybe 35 or $50,000
that's pretty doable I had some some
friends who needed finishing funds of
200 and they raised 210 or so so it is
possible to to do if you have an
appealing subject the first thing that I
did was go to a friend of mine named
Michael Green who had been the uh head
of nerys that's the group that gives out
the Grammy Awards and I had known
Michael for about 15 years and um I
called him up and said I have a project
that I think you might be interested in
so he said well what is it so I told him
briefly on the phone he said well what
have you got on it I said well right now
all I have is a bunch of pictures and
some stories so I had a photo I had
photographs I made a book
uh you know
like uh you know a folder that had a lot
of of the photographs of the women in it
and I wrote up the stories of each of
them that I had done after this year of
research and I went up to see Michael
and gave him the book and he said yeah
this looks interesting what do you want
and I said I want enough money to make a
demo
real and he said okay I'll give you the
money so we did we went out and we shot
our first interviews and we did a
7-minute demo
reel and with that demo reel we then
went out to Major funders and started
asking for money for the project so that
was our first
steps I was in the process of finding my
source my funding for the feature film
and I was searching for like
$300,000 it was like it's a lot of money
so I was like can I make when that idea
was just like can I make that story of
the under eyes and and just re because I
had a version of the script and can I
just re shape everything to make it
around 60 Grand 85 Grand and I scale it
down and I was asking favors from people
and you know it's kind of cliche but
yeah you ask people favors sponsors and
uh then it worked out and uh it just
sometime by doing something it clicks an
idea and when I did that short film that
was the revelation of oh let's screw to
300 let's make it for maybe 60 and I'm
sure it's going to be easier to find
investors and it worked I doesn't think
I'm from Montreal but I don't shoot in
Montreal so I cannot use government
money grants and yeah I cannot use Grant
and stuff like that and then when I go
to the states I cannot apply because I'm
not American so I don't have any choice
to go into the private funding so I I
was lucky I you know people where did
you find that money I just ask everyone
and it's I didn't want to do the
kickstarter thing you need to have Army
to do those things and I didn't I don't
I don't have the patient to do that when
I want to shoot something I want to
shoot it now and uh so I asked people
and people people people and that's the
thing where you have at least short
films music videos and you have amazing
demo real you have a good material to
show to people and you have a business
plan that's what I did I did a business
plan I have my great demo beautiful
website to at least showcase everything
and then it's easier to contact people
so I had one person that loved my work
say oh I got someone in Texas who uh can
maybe was interested so I talked to the
guy I show him my work business plan and
he said yes so it's a lot of people
always it's who you know but yeah it's
kind of true it's going to be impossible
if you never done short film or you just
barely start you don't have a great demo
re and you think you're going to have
like
$250,000 there's no I don't know good
luck with that because people work with
visual you need to be able to show you
know just even for my business plan it
was mostly all pictures so yes you have
the numbers and everything but that's
for business people that's important but
at the same time they want to see that
you have your Clear Vision because
that's what they're investing in you
know a Clear Vision that oh is going to
make some money but uh so yeah the fact
that you have your style your signature
that you have a buddy of work then
that's going to be more impressive and
then if you they Google you and you have
magazine and the interviews whatever
that you they see that you've traveled a
little bit it's way more reinsuring that
you f I just came out of the school and
I hope to get $300 $300,000 because I
wore I wrote a script who cares there's
like million people who does that so at
least a visual to apply to that business
plan in my experience they don't want
they want to see a written pitch but
they don't want it to be 40 pages they
want it to be between five and 10 pages
that they can get the idea of your film
that quickly and nowadays if you can put
any kind of pitch reel together Sizzle
reel kind of trailer I know you haven't
shot it yet supposedly but maybe you can
maybe for free on your own dime you can
go down to your subject and get an
afternoon with them and get them on tape
and if you shoot it with your hdslr and
you and you cut it on your your Cloud
editing system you put it together for
very little and you have their Stills
which you can license and you so you put
together a little two-minute Pitch movie
along with a five-page pitch you that's
all you need they're going to get it
from that so at least come in with those
two things and and you have a shot I
have to say I call it a no budget which
is because we had to spend like I'd say
between 5,000 and 6,000 which is no
budget in terms of of movie making and
they were all um private savings so so
we we went and make the movie with
literally uh no phones and no one
involved so so so in a way it was um it
was making us feel free
and but I mean I think that even though
that was the story of this movie I would
tell young filmmakers not to be afraid
of
of getting um money you have to go and
get the money where it is out there so
so so getting investors is not a bad
thing it is not going to ruin your
Creative Vision on the contrary I think
that the best on the contrary it can be
seen as a limit but if you are as
serious and as good as a filmmaker you
will always find a way to go around that
and you to tell your story the story you
have uh in your heart in your mind so I
don't think that would be a limit even
when a lot of people are putting money
from everywhere and then ask for people
to um for certain kind of things but uh
it's like every other limit on the movie
set on I mean when you're making movie
there are a lot of of
limits and there are a lot of obstacles
and you just have to go around it around
the mountain and just find a way to just
continue and keep telling the story we
just wanted to shoot that fast that we
had the money there uh sleeping for us
so so we just went out and made the
movie and we didn't want to toar way too
long for cred founding and to and to put
our hopes um on hold you know it's like
when you when you're doing CED founding
you it's great but you you can also
be waiting longer and longer than
expected and then the the level of of uh
interest for the story and commitment is
getting down and down and down so
whereas for Pingo it was kind of a yeah
for me the reference in the way we did
this film is Roger comman we just when
inde did Roger Comm kind of film with
just no budget and Just sh it for the
sake of the
story with just the help of friends and
or private savings for me this one was
primarily to bring them to C my teth in
and uh the next one the way I'm writing
it right now is on a much bigger scale
uh uh and even though it's very uh
granted to reality it will involve much
more money uh so so I'm open to any kind
of Investments can be can go from
crowdfunding to uh private investors
it's uh we will go where who will be
interested to to finance it I know that
with especially with the film festivals
where I'm presenting pingone right now A
lot of people are asking me okay what's
next and I'm talking about them about
this story and I so I met these people
who are because they so p on and loved
it so much they are committed to maybe
help Finance the next one and so that's
why this movie also is great as a way to
engage people to finance the next one
and that's why also for the next film
festivals we're going to do with ping
Zone uh especially the big ones in
Europe we're going to still continue uh
present pingone as a way to finance the
next one every feature film that I've
done has gotten financed differently
because it's what you do when you get
there it's sort of like there's no plan
if I was independently wealthy or had
some sort of you know whatever there's
no there's no plan it's just it's what
you do at the time with uh 10 till noon
we raised money through through
traditional investors you know we burned
through a lot of favors and we burned
through a lot of money people with
official rejection we ended up um self
financing the whole movie it was it was
but you know but a lot of that
piggybacked 10 till noon so and that was
we were able to do pretty cheaply we
deferred a lot of money in that film so
we really did it that way with um favor
we crowdfunded it and uh that was you
know the new thing to do and that worked
so for the next one I'm not sure what
we're going to do it's kind of like you
can't kind of do the same thing twice
you know I mean why I find with well
with with traditional distributor with
traditional sorry wow distrib we talk
about so much with traditional
investors you sort of you know they're
going to lose money probably and if they
make money great but if they do it's in
the long game so until the film's made
money it's hard to go back to the same
person and go hey by the way another 10
grand what do you think another 30 grand
it's very hard very hard to do that
because it takes a lot of years for to
profitable so you know in the rare case
you get a hit but you know and the thing
is we're friendly with them all it's not
they're like oh where's our money but
you know they're not you don't want to
go back and try to tap them again you
want to go to the next round so it
that's why you kind of don't want to go
to the same place twice until you can
come back with really really good news
Andy we finally you know have some uh
profit for you um self financing is hard
because you burn through your money you
know quickly and um it picks a while for
that to build back up and then with
crowdfunding I think you it's the same
thing you go back to that
well the second time especially before
the first one's out I think it's hard I
think you can do it Gary King's doing
his Third crowdfunding campaign um I
think it's more successful you do it in
small burst too I know one guy uh this
filming Gorman who does him he's always
got a campaign going but they're only
like a th000 bucks 2,000 bucks and he
just and he's raised lots of money but
he just keeps feeding and people kind of
keep double dipping triple dipping
because it's a
small um that's one way of doing it um
but you know it's like uh you have to
wait it's like it's like harvesting
fruit you know you got wait for the
fruit to grow back uh with the new film
that we're putting together now small
hours we're trying to go to back to
traditional investors again but we're
going to try to hit different ones and
we're going to try to go for more money
this time so that's sort of how that
works um I think it's really depending
upon the film the time it's being made
and what you have available to you at
that time you'll find a way you know
that's that's the way to go I think that
you have to have a real
sense
of of where people are coming
from of what's going on with them that
makes this possible for them or
not and you have to live within the
reality of that and maybe a no is a no
now but is not a no in the future
and and then you know there's some
people who say take me off your list
well if they say that then it's a
no you say okay we're sorry we bothered
you and you know you have to do that too
because you will be bothering a lot of
people who don't want to be bothered
about this who have their own problems
or their own projects that they're
raising money for so you just have to be
very sensitive uh every step of the way
I don't think you can afford to be hurt
you your your personal feelings have got
to be left left on the doorstep
somewhere else you are in a very
very difficult and dynamic situation
when you're fundraising and there really
is no room for personal feelings of hurt
or
rejection that's you got to just get rid
of that it's not useful to you in any
way this is just a job you're doing and
you won't be successful at every phase
of it but overall you will be successful
uccessful and that's what you look for
oh I was not thick skinn I was your your
typical uh fragile young girl who was
easily
hurt uh but you know you you learn you
get out there and you tough it out and
you learn and and that's what you do and
then all of a sudden you wake up one day
and say Hey you know that doesn't bother
me anymore I don't care who are
they you know you're you're Who You Are
and that's that's what you're searching
for all the time and once you find that
once you find your own personal strength
nobody can shake that I have a little
sign that I put on my computer that
another producer said I found it in I
don't know some magazine said if anyone
says no to you and you're discouraged
for one second you're
dead Okay meaning I cannot indulge
myself in any kind of uh self-pity
whatsoever I got too many other people
to talk to who are going to say
yes that has been a real help for
me